وداعا جوليا قصه حب تروي ماساه وطن فيلم
صنع الفرق في تاريخ السينما السودانيه
بالفعل حجز مقعدا للسودان ولاول مره في
تاريخها في مهرجان كان السينمائي في نسخته
67 وحصد جائزه الحريه فرحه طبعا ممزوجه
بالحزن نتيجه صراع الدائر في ارض الوطن في
السودان وداعا جوليا يصنف كفيلم الروائي
وينتمي الى الدراما الاجتماعيه قصه تروي
تاثير انفصال جنوب السودان على عن السودان
عام 2011 والامل لتشكيل هويه وطنيه جديده
تجمع الناس تحت مظله التعايش والسلام
[تصفيق]
كانه يقتلك
طيب
العقوبه ده هنقعد فيها لحد
الله كريم
صباح الخير يا محمد صباح النور مبروك على
جائزه الحريه الله يبارك هذه المشاركه
في هذه النسخه في مهرجان كان ولكن هل تنبا
الفيلم بما ياتي الى السودان اليوم هل هو
البكاء على اللبن المسكوب باعتبار انه
انفصال جنوب السودان ام الوضع الحالي وانت
تحصد هذه الجائزه
2018 بديت كتابه لكن الحقيقه الفكره بدات
من قبل كده بكثير يمكن من اول ما انا شفت
النتيجه بتاعه استفتاء انفصال جنوب
السودان وكانت نتيجه ملفت بالنسبه ليلى
انها
98.7 من عشره فحسيت انه النتيجه دي
بالتاكيد هي ما نتيجه سياسيه هي شيله
وعلاقه بالوضع الاجتماعي الحاصل بين بين
الشعبين يعني
في 2018 كان يا دب بديت اكتب
وبديت حقيقه لانه انا كنت عارف انه انا
عايز ابدا او اكتب عن الفتره الانتقاليه
من 2005 ل 2011
فبديت اكتب الحبكه وبعد بديت اختار شخصيات
ممكن تكون ملائمه للقصه
واستله الشخصيات دي من حياتي الشخصيه يعني
واخر مرحله جاءت هي الحوار وفي الحوار
ساعدني
شاب اسمه خالد الوليد وبشكره من هنا
كان ايام او ليالي طويله قبل التصوير هي
اخر مرحله كنا دائما بنتكلم بنقعد مع بعض
فتره طويله جدا وبنتناقش وبنتشاكل مرات
كمان
بين بين طاقم العمل هي هي خليني اسالك
بانه انا كنت في الفاشر وذهبت الى بورت
سودان وغيرها من الاماكن هناك هذه
الفسيفساء الاجتماعيه السودانيه وخصائصها
الى اي مدى كانت هذه الرؤيه الاخراجيه
تحكس حقيقه الوضع خاصه انك اسميت وداعا
جوليا هل ستلحق جوليا جوليا اخرى وان كان
الاسم مختلفا ايوه حقيقه انا دائما يعني
قيمه الفيلم هي الانفصال والانفصال على
مستويات كثيره جدا يعني مش بس انفصال
البلد ولكن دي اكثر حاجه ظاهره في الفيلم
ولكن انفصال الاسره وانفصال الاحبه
وانفصال الازواج وانفصال يعني كل الانفصال
في وداعا وان كان
دائما انا في في يعني في عقل الباطن كان
عندي خوف من انفصال جديد في السودان
فعشان كذا
حاولت بشكل ما انه اقدر اطرح قضيه
الانفصال بتاعه الجنوب دي واستحملك يعني
كفرس نقدر نعاين به
لمشاكل جديده بتاعه انفصال ممكن تحصل او
ناقوس معنى ذلك قبل ما ينتهي وقت
نا ماوي تكمل في
نفس وفي
نفس يعني
مشروعك المستقبلي فيلم بيحكيه يمكن عن
الوضع الراهن الان في السودان ما اعرف
مفتقرين وداعا جوليا لانه بعد عشر سنين من
الانفصال كان عندي نظره يعني ايوه اكثر
بقدر اشوف بها الوضع لكن الان الحرب صعب
جدا اقدر اكتب قصه وانا في في خضم يعني
الحرب حتى مشاعريه عن اتجاهها حتكون ما
مشاعرك تسمح لي بالكتابه وما بالضروره
اكتب حاجه سياسيه يعني بتخيل انه ممكن
الفيلم الجاي يكون حاجه اجتماعيه
ان شاء الله راح نستضيفها كمان كم سنه
بجائزه اخرى من مهرجان كان على الاقل ما
يكون الوداعي
اهلا اهلا جوليا وربما اي سما محمد شكرا
جزيلا لك ويعني من
رحم المعاناه قد تولد ايضا
الابداع يولد الابداع وكذلك الجوائز
ومؤلف فيلم وداعا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات